good morning gamers why are we on the
ground ken
we're supposed to be in the sky we fell
from the sky
we fell from the sky we need to get back
up again there's only one reason we got
to get back
up you know why that is the floor is
lava
the floor will soon be lava it's coming
it's coming we gotta save this precious
chicken from the lava
follow me chicken no no no chicken don't
follow him follow me
so we definitely did not steal this from
anyone else but basically every minute
or so
lava will rise from the surface it will
rise
we should probably start getting
probably starting to try to survive
right
yes quick felix make a cobblestone
generator
hey don't you dare say those words to me
and yeah you know what i'll do it speed
run we're not gonna need a cobblestone
generator what do you mean
oh you already oh so fast i told you bro
never challenged me again lava is about
to come are you ready
no i'm not ready i'm making sticks over
here ten blocks of llama ken
my god okay so that's the first level of
lava where where's the lava
like a sea level probably okay oh thank
god
we also gotta protect these villagers we
gotta save all the people we gotta save
everyone we're like noah's ark but
swedish edition
and american oh my god they have
potatoes in here
hey we got pumpkins you guys are rich
robbed them
all right they can all die now
no we have to save them okay i got i got
pumpkins ken don't worry oh good
very good i'm just gonna loot these guys
get everything useful out of them what
is this is this guy making like an
enchanted sword over here
you can trade them i think 16 emeralds
for an iron sword
knockback one is sharpness two get out
of here you ring the bell
let him know let him know what's coming
lava is coming boy
the end is near run hey you can sleep
should we go to sleep they got awesome
houses
yeah he's pretty cool oh there's some
you made an advancement good job
oh yeah somebody has to play for the
lava ken
you're just walking around with money
money's not going to be good when
everyone's dead
ken look come here come here let me show
you that's good for me come here look at
me
you gonna punch me and make it rain all
right
all right all right there you go
all right here you can have some bread
too no
don't walk away from my bread are you
talking about good job okay chicken it's
okay we're gonna survive chicken's gonna
die what do we need what do we need to
build
what do we need to survive lava rising
from the ground start digging the can
get to work we're gonna dig you'll be a
dig for
more lava is coming kid 15 blocks got
filled my god the lava is coming ken
where is it i don't see i don't i don't
believe it's coming okay okay you want
to see it coming
global warming isn't happening i can't
see with my own eyes okay
same again save me blow on me
okay i'll put you out oh god the lava is
real ken
do you believe it now oh god
oh god all i have is an egg
everything's on fire no it came out of
nowhere the fire nation attacked and oh
my god
oh put it out again you're on the other
side
ah piggy save the pigs ken
i'm sorry i doubted you oh the trees i
told you global warming real
i told you many times the llamas is
gonna keep rising ken
here you are talking about college loans
what good is it gonna do you now
look i believe scots and they're talking
about you know like black holes and
things in space but when they come to
talking about the planet getting warmer
no i don't believe science then until
now
piggy the world's burning around us i'm
just a skeptic
you know i have an open mind
looking at you and just everything
around you is on fire
it's fine it's this is mine
i'm trying to get to you dude you're not
helping
i'm sorry you're just laughing where'd
my
go i was in the lava work no
work man it was like father to me
all right i'm coming wood is fine right
it won't turn on fire or anything right
yeah of course not okay oh god i hope
this bridge
works do it oh
god oh oh god can't
help me oh my bridge is on fire
hurry up just jump you got this
i jump
you made it i made it thank god again
thank god we gotta get taller the love
is coming you're right
and we get to the high i try to warn you
bro i told you about the stairs bro
oh god
all the animals have dead we failed
get to the trees oh you're taking the
trees down
oh god no oh my god
what have i done oh what is that gonna
be able to we have nothing but wood
we're gonna do the threes i gotta take
this house down to get some stone
hey oh look who finally made it to the
stone age huh yeah i did it
hey don't talk to that guy he's not
gonna help us okay we gotta save the pig
do you have potatoes
what yes i have potatoes you eat
potatoes yeah yeah thanks brother that's
bread
just kidding potatoes ah goddammit
potato no no
no no he loves it he loves it we have to
protect where you have to protect it by
the whole college
that's right peter will be very angry
peter be like
bruh okay i'll make new workbench here
you go this is like
origin story to skyblocks yeah we gotta
we gotta build this guy
this is the prequel we gotta get to this
guy skin
you know real talk about skyblock yeah
it's kinda boring
it's like where all the minecraft pros
go to flex they're eating but you just
sit there and
you just you just you just come on
cobblestone
bro he's roasting the nine-year-olds
everyone's probably like why are you
guys playing sky block what what happens
if we
water lava proof a house what's the plan
here i'm freaking out man
get the pig inside the church where's
the church at
we have a church right here it's right
here there's a church i need some jesus
in my life uh-oh zombie
oh my god there's zombies and lava
come here piggy yeah that's a good piggy
our last bastion
get to the church ken piggy chicken when
in need
go to god get in the church game
it's the pig pig hurry get in here
oh my god he's having fun with you he's
having a stroke please
all right is there any holes in this
building the lava's coming from the
ground it's going to get in here
we can't stop it oh god we have to climb
oh you're right it doesn't matter
oh god i'm so stupid oh god look out
it's right there oh my god
first it's gonna eat me and then it's
gonna oh wait that was wrong
it's okay oh the lava ah
we're not doing a pretty good job i
think we're trying to get oh the trees
oh wait how did the lava get in here
i'm going to the roof camp with my piggy
it's do or die ken
let's do it oh my god
get on the ceiling dude i think we got
the coordinates we're outside of the
lava region right now
but i think if we keep increasing it it
will pour over
oh my god i don't have enough food to
survive
oh thanks for sharing bro i did i threw
bread at you you took some already
oh you're right thanks bro
[Laughter]
that's coming we're not time for sleep
okay i'm awake i'm woke bro
i'm walking to the lava okay wait we
should probably go here
and then just go up here there we go i'm
burning
up ah blowing me blow on me
you're making it worse
oh my god the lava
it's everywhere everything's on fire oh
god i got
oh no this tree that i'm standing on is
probably now on fire
you'll be fine ken you'll be fine down
here you go there's a piece of stone for
you to stand on as
we wait for our inevitable death we
didn't save
anybody stone golem is fine don't worry
oh stone golem holding down bro
hold down the fort bruh ken i have a bad
feeling about stone golem
[Laughter]
i'm sorry bro oh no
we didn't even pick the highest spot we
got to make it over there ken
okay okay then just follow me everything
will be fine
oh wait i need to make slabs so i can
make it sleep don't run out
wait i can't wait again don't worry bro
i got you
right there oh my god you're my hero ken
i got you boo don't worry okay now it's
gotta we
did we did this skype skype we just need
water now if we can make
infinite cobblestone oh my god yes we
just need water
keep spitting he's spitting
he spits out now i'm saving world from
global warming
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
is this the end again i want you to know
that
i never really liked you look
the sun is rising on the lava oh my god
there's hope
is gandalf gonna come at the horizon oh
god the sun is going to bless
us i always hated you the most i never
liked you anyway
don't you dare push me down how many
minutes oh how many materials do you
have
stop goodbye forever
how dare you stop knocking down my tower
i just need the materials bro get away
from my tower oh god this is it really
is like sky blocks
don't worry i dropped something for you
here you go bro oh it filled the lava
too bad
come on bro oh it's in the lava tube
stop
throwing the bread in the lava oh that
water
oh god everything is getting in the lava
oh i hear villagers dying how poor
villagers
did you hear that no i can't hear i
can't hear anything up here everything's
everything's fine
you can't hear anything up here okay
top of my tower looking down at these
peasants
what are you doing up there throwing it
throw some stuff down
all right i got you ready give me some
material yes
yes good job
what do you mean good job there you go
here's some more here's some more you
ready all right
catch it stop it's okay ken i have a new
strategy
hey i got more you need some more be
quiet
all right here here it comes catch it
oh i got it i got it thanks bro screw
you
i'm out of here get out of there nobody
has no
no no oh my god
i gave you too much
no no hey don't touch it
don't touch it love is coming king no
whatever you're doing oh i think we won
no blocks were filled this is nauseat
oh my god
ah you son of a snake i almost got you
yeah you take that
oh you don't exit me bro
hey ken look it's sky blocks
no better better plant a tree
when this tree grows again i'm gonna get
you
grow take that please
oh wait i have i have an idea do you
have one oh there's more dirt perfect
no my dirt
when i'm dead you can't leech any more
subscribers off me ken
you don't like me anyway they never
subscribe anyway
you'll regret this a million people
watch the video and 4 000 people
subscribed
god i'm getting nauseous looking at the
lava really yeah
what a big baby big brain there hey look
at me
how dare you get locked out scrub
no stop stop no no you stop
don't you break it you stop that no
pick it back up yeah get wrecked how
about that i have half a health bar
why did you build with a pumpkin because
i needed i need it don't ask me
those questions those trees aren't going
to grow they're too close together oh my
god
you think you know minecraft i know if
you place them like that they're
supposed to grow
wait put the door in the lava oh
give me the door it's our only hope out
of here it's our only chance to sit back
they're only changed it's our
[Applause]
okay hey don't push me off
i'm not gonna put you up what are you
even standing on
don't worry about that i didn't think it
would end like this
i think the door's down there it keeps
like going in and burning is the door is
doing god's work
i told you the door would save us again
door dad
was dead how many blocks do you have
left ken i have two
two wooden blocks no
how dare you
you think i know what you're trying to
do
you should
did he even respawn what got a respawn
uh
deep deep in some lava are the trees are
still down here it burns what
i can't swim up because there's trees
above me
how is the cobblestone burning he's
returned
for revenge
where am i i have the hike around
cinematography no
stop stop don't even know the quote
you have the high ground don't even try
again i can who are
oh my god how did you make it wow
he survived he was in your pocket the
whole time
we have to repopulate now ken you i
think you know what to do
i have been training my whole life my
red
come here piggy no you and me not the
pig what
oh piggy can join too right peggy
what you never played two for simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price